shut
up
we're definitely feeling lucky that Silk
Sonic performing their hit 777 while
opening the 2022 Grammy Awards in Las
Vegas
[Music]
I mean you're gonna get everything you
expect from select Sonic it's high
energy it's fun
um it's going to give you a little bit
of a reason to get up and dance at the
top of the show I think it's just the
energy that we need to open a big show
in Vegas so we're excited as the Grammys
executive producer previewed ahead of
the show Bruno Mars and Anderson Park
brought the crowd to their feet and
moving to the groove with this funky
tracks
downstairs
[Music]
on 70s inspired looks definitely giving
Elvis Presley vibes
[Music]
and talk Sonic is celebrating big on
Grammy night they took home three
trophies including best R B rap song
song of the year and record of the year
for their first single together leave
the door open and you know because of
you guys me and Andy gonna be singing
this song forever so God bless you all
the rest of our lives we love you Mars
and park made their live debut at the
2021 Grammys with the hit song If Bruno
Mars ever said to you may I join your
event you should just say yes the
singers dropped their first album from
their smooth collab and evening with
silk Sonic last November and are
continuing to change the music game with
their hits
[Music]
the duo is no stranger to performing in
Sin City as they are fresh off their
debut residency at the Dolby live
theater at Park MGM which began in
February and runs through late May in
the meantime fans are sure to leave the
door open for some new Tunes from these
two
[Music]
and I'm hoping
[Music]